hey guys I wanted to show you a very
quick recipe for an amazing drink for
blood Sugar's insulin resistance and
even if you have diabetes okay we're
gonna combine several ingredients where
I'd like to use these little mason jars
with the top so first thing I do is I
add the cinnamon cinnamon has some
powerful anti-diabetic properties so
we're gonna put about a teaspoon of
cinnamon okay right here then I like to
use fresh ginger okay I use one of these
shave about a teaspoon and put that in
this drink - ginger again it's has
amazing phytochemicals and a lot of
different properties for a lot of
different health issues but specifically
blood sugars of course we can't forget
the apple cider vinegar I like Bragg's
and I will use one tablespoon you can
use two and then of course the organic
lemon juice okay great for Aikido and in
a min a fasting program to prevent
kidney stones so with this one I'll do
like two or even three or four I like
lemon and then we'll do so take some you
can take filtered water I like kind of
Pellegrino
and I will just fill this up a little
bit cover it up shake so I'll make a
couple of these I'll take like two a day
and then what I'll do is I will keep in
the fridge and I'll drink one not right
when I'm drinking the kale shake but
like and then not necessarily with the
meal but sometimes I will okay so of
course with its carbonated water it's
gonna blow up here okay
so that's pretty much the simplicity of
how do you make this amazing drink go
ahead and try it out and see what
happens to your blood Sugar's I think
you're gonna be quite surprised
pleasantly surprised all right thanks
for watching
hey guys I want to personally invite you
to a new Facebook group that I just
started called dr. Berg's Kido and in a
minute fasting lab ok so I created this
so we can share our successful actions
what worked what didn't work your
results so I've put a link down below so
go ahead and sign up and I'll see you
inside